شكرا للزميل نايف اعزائي المشاهدين وتابع
معكم هذه التغطيه المتواصله لزلزال سوريا
وتركيا وهو الزلزال الذي اقرت الامم
المتحده انه اسوا حدث تشهده المنطقه في
مئه عام الرئيس التركي اعلى ارتفاع عدد
قتل الزلزال الى اكثر من 21 الفا اما
المرصد السوري فقد اعلن ارتفاع حصيله
القتلى في سوريا وحدها الى خمسه الاف
ومئتي قتيل وبذلك تجاوز عدد القتل اكثر من
26 الفا في كلا البلدين مع ترجيحات
بارتفاع العدد مع اضمحلال الامل بالعثور
على ناجي
الا ان الامل بالحياه لا يختفي فدائما
هناك استثناءات تعكس النظريات والحسابات
العربيه كانت شاهده اليوم على انقاذ ثلاثه
اطفال من قهرمان مرعش بعد سته ايام عاشوها
تحت الانقاب وسنتابع هذه المشاهد بعد قليل
الان الى كلمه للرئيس تركي رجب طيب
اردوغان
[موسيقى]
بالطبع كان الرئيس التركي رجب اردوغان
بالامس قد حذر من عمليات نهب وسلب يقوم
بها البعض للمحال التجاريه والمولات
مستغلا هذا الحدث الماساوي وقال ان سلطات
التركيه لن تسمح
بذلك ايضا حذر الذين يستغلون سياسيا هذه
الماساه من اجل اغراضهم الخاصه لنستمع الى
ما يقول
طبعا هنا شهدت بعض التاخيرات وبعض النقص
لكن
[موسيقى]
لكن النضال المستميت والكفاح المستميت
الذي بذلته بلادنا بشعبها ودولتها لا يمكن
لاحد ان ينكره اذ هو واضح لكل ذي عيان
وطوال فتره
الزلزال وفتره
الكارثه شهدنا مره اخرى كيف ان شعبنا هو
شعب عزيز متاخر متضامن
بهذا الشعب المتضامن
[موسيقى]
هذا الشعب البذول سيتجاوز هذه الازمه
وباذن الله بهذا الشعب بشعب هكذا
سنتجاوز واؤمن جازما الناس سنتجاوز كل
كارثه ولا يمكنني كارثه بهذا الشعب
اعتبارا من يوم الخميس انتهينا من اعمال
البحث وانقاذ في
اعمال رفع الانقراض والاعمال الاخرى
سننهيها في اقرب فتره ممكنه ونبدا اعمال
الانشاء واعاده احياء هذه المنكوبه سابقا
في
ظننتيا شهدت زلازل وايضا في
شاهدنا سيولا كما شهينا في انطاليا وموضه
حرائق
هذه مناطق المنكوبه جميعكم
شهد كيف اننا احيينا هذه المنطقه بعد هذه
الكوارث ومثل ما قمنا بذلك واحنا هذه
المناطق ان شاء الله سنضمن الجراحات هذه
المناطق المنكوبه في زلزال الاخير ان شاء
الله كما قمنا بالخطوات ونقوم بالخطوات
الذي التي تخفف من اثر هذا الزلزال ونقوم
بها بهذه الخطوات اولا باول
المواطنين الذين فقدوا منازلهم وباتت
منازلهم في وضع لا يصلحوا السكن وفرنا لهم
ونوفر امكانيات السكن في المحافظات نفسها
والمحافظات المجاوره ايضا وفي هذا الاطار
فالفنادق والسكنات الطلابيه الموجوده في
جميع انحاء محافظاتنا
خصصنا اماكن
لاولئك المنكوبين فقط التابع ضمن المؤسسات
المنشات التابعه لوزاره التربيه والتعليم
وفرنا ايواء ل 460 الف مواطن
كما انه في
اماكن الاقامه المؤقته يوجد مليون ومئه
الف شخص ياوي هناك
كما انه وبشكل يغطي كل اصحاب المنازل
واصحاب البيوت المستاجره
شكلنا برنامجا للدعم بالايجاري يتراوح
يغطي المساحه بين الاسعار بين
500 5000 ليره كما
قرارا
سنمنح بناء عليه خمسه عشر الف ليره
للعائلات المنكوبه
كما نتخذ كل التدابير التي تعين مواطنين
على
تضميد جراحهم
ونسعى في هذه الايام الصعبه لان لا نتمكن
مواطنين وحدهم ونقوم بكل اللازم لكي
ناويهم ونسد كل احتياجاتهم ونقوم باللازم
وسنقوم بكل ما يلزم في هذا الاطار
بعض
المحافظات سنحيها من جديد
سنعود انشاء المشاريع هذه المرحله التي
تشمل اعاده انشاء 100
وحده سكنيه نؤمن الجازمين باننا سينجح في
هذه المرحله اطلب منكم سنه واحده باذن
الله خلال عام واحد
سنقوم بانشاء هذه الوحده السكنيه وسنحيها
بسكانها مره اخرى
وهذا وكما كان في كل مرحله من مراحل
تاريخنا المشرف سنقضي هذه المرحله ضمن
تعاون وتضامن
كامل
[موسيقى]
والمناطق المنكوبه ضمن هذه الاطارات
والحالات الطارئه
قمنا بوضع كل الاليات اللازمه
لاعاده الحياه الى امورها الطبيعيه
وكما مددنا عطله التربيه والتعليم الى
تاريخ 20 شباط في كل محافظات التركيه
وايضا في المدارس التي هي موجوده في
المناطق
لن يطلب دوام الزامي من طلاب المدارس في
المناطق المنكوبه
وايضا نرجو العائلات الذين يرغبون في نقل
اولادهم الى مدارس اخرى في محافظات اخرى
توفر لهم التسهيلات اللازمه وايضا
للعاملين والتجار وكل قطاعات الشعب نقوم
بخطوات مماثله لتوفير تسهيلات اللازمه
كما نواصل علاج وحمايه الاطفال الذين تم
انقاذهم دون عائلاتهم ونواصل الاعمال في
هذا الاطار كما نقلنا مرضانا
والجرحى
[موسيقى]
جويا وبريا وبحريا وستتم متابعه علاجاتهم
ومعالجتهم عن كثب
[موسيقى]
الخطوات اللازمه لاولئك الذين يقومون
باعمال النهب
وكذلك من يرفعون الاسعار ويغالون فيها وقد
اصدرنا التعليمات اللازمه لوزاره التجاره
وغيرها في هذا الاطار كما اننا نقوم
بخطوات
التدابير اللازمه لمن يتداولون المعلومات
المغلوطه وحملات التشويه والتحريض على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ولن نتسامح ولا نكون متسامحين معهم نحن
كشعب وكدوله كما تجاوزنا العديد من
الكوارث والنكبات ان شاء الله سنخرج من
هذا من هذه الكارثه ايضا
جبيننا وضاح لامع صلوات خلال المرحله
السابقه
[موسيقى]
والتسبيحات وذكر الله
شهدائنا وثم
سنواصل الانتقال الى مشاجع الاحياء
والانجاء والانشاء نحن امه وشعب يؤمن بان
بان مع كل عسر يسرا
ليست لدي
ادنى ريبه في انها سنتجاوز هذه الكارثه
اسال الله العون واحييكم مره اخرى ومرارا
دمتم في امان الله
كنا مع هذه الكلمه للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان بالطبع في كل يوم هو رئيس التركي
يتفقد المناطق التي ضربها زلزال ويقوم
بمؤتمر الصحفيه ابرز ما قاله انه عدد
القتلى في تركيا وحدها
تجاوز
21,848 قتيلا ايضا قال ان شعبنا سيتجاوز
هذه الماساه بمزيد من التصميم والاراده
وان السلطات في تركيا ستعيد اعمار كل ما
تهدم وبشكل افضل تحدث عن اجراءات بحق كل
من تسول له نفسه سرقه المحال او المواد
مواد التغذيه وختم بالقول ان مع كل عسر
يسرا اذا وفي ظل تواصلي عمليات البحث عن
ناجين على الرغم من اضمحلال فرص العثور
عليهم شهدت العربيه اليوم على انقاذ ثلاثه
اطفال من قهرمان مرعش بعد سته ايام عاشوها
تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله الله يعطيكم جميعا الحمد لله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد لله
وحده تسع سنين
الله يسلمك
[موسيقى]
الامل في قهرمان مرعش لم ينسحب على جميع
من ينتظر خبرا من تحت الركام عن احبائه
فقط اظهر مقطع فيديو متداول ابا تركيا وهو
يصرخ باسماء افراد عائلته املا في اي
اشاره على بقائهم احياء تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
الى قهرمان مرعش ينضم اليه لمزيد من
المتابعه موفد العربيه غسان ابو لوز الذي
يتابع تغطيه احداث هذا الزلزال اولا باول
غسان اهلا وسهلا بك يعطيك الف عافيه اول
شيء جديد المشهد من عندك وهل ما زال هنالك
ولو بصيص امل بسيط بالعثور على ناجين كونك
كنت شاهد انت بشكل شخصي على انقاذ هؤلاء
الاطفال الثلاثه يعني بعد نحو سته ايام من
وجودهم تحت الركام ام لا يجري التعاطي
الان مع كل من بقي تحت الركام على انهم
بحكم الاموات
طالب هناك امل ما زالت فرق الانقاذ تواصل
العمليات البحث يعني ورصد العالقين تحت
الانقاض باستخدام الوسائل المختلفه بما
فيها الحيوانات
والطرق الحديثه
اليات الحديثه كالكاميرات الحراريه وغيرها
وما الى ذلك ايضا العمليات متواصله حتى
هذه اللحظه في جميع مناطق المناطق التي
تعرضت الى زلزال وجميع مناطق المنكوبه
والعمليات مستمره ليلا نهارا طالب يعني
كما تحدثت هو اليوم السادس تتضاءل فرص
النجاه للعالقين تحت الانقاذ لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه نحن كنا شاهدين على انقاذ ثلاث
طفلات صغيرات 11 سنه وتسع سنوات وسبع
سنوات وتم انتشالهم بنجاح وارسالهم الى
المستشفيات وهم بحاله صحيه جيده ووضعهم
جيد جدا الان لكن هناك اجراءات طبيه يجب
ان يتواصلوا فيها طالب وبالتالي الامل
موجود حتى هذه اللحظه لكن عامل الوقت كما
تعلم طالب ليس في صالح العالقين تحت
الانقاذ ان كان هناك ناجين وايضا الظروف
التي يعيشون فيها من غير ماء ولا طعام ولا
تدفئه خصوصا في ظل ظروف جويه قاسيه جدا
ودرجات حراره تتدنى الى ما دون الصفر في
الليل نحن نقف الان عند احد المباني نشاهد
كما تشاهد الان عمال الانقاذ يحملون هذه
الستائر وعلى ما يبدو على ما يبدو طالب
بانه يعني يحاولون انتشال جثه من هذا
المكان للاسف طبعا هذا المبنى كباقي
المباني في مدينه كهرمان مرعش وباقي المدن
المدمره يواصل العمال الانقاذ منذ اليوم
الاول ولغايه اليوم السادس هنا حيث نقف
طالب يعني سالنا لكن لا توجد انباء عن
عالقين في هذا الشارع الذي نقف فيه علما
بان الشارع الذي نقف فيه طالب فيه العشرات
من البيوت
المدمره وهو شارع اخر غير الذي كنا فيه في
الرساله السابقه طالب هذا هو الحال في
تعريف غسان كونك انت اقرب منا الى الاحداث
والان يعني حتى في بعض يعني على مواقع
التواصل يطلب مني ان اسالك عن البنات
الثلاث الذين يعني تم انقاذهم بعد نحو سته
ايام اولا هل هم بصحه جيده يسالون الى اي
مستشفى نقلوا ماذا عن اهاليهم هل هم احياء
اذا كان لديك معلومات غسان لانه المشاهد
التي رايناها يعني مؤثره جدا بالنسبه
نعم طالب بالنسبه للطفلات الثلاث
حالتهم الصحيه جيده جدا لكن هم بحاجه
لتدخل طبي خصوصا انهم بقيوا لمده سته ايام
هناك نقص في التغذيه وهناك يعني امور اخرى
يجب اتخاذها اجراءات طبيه يجب اتخاذها في
مثل هذه الحالات هم يعني الان هناك طفله
تم نقلهما الى مستشفى اخر بعيد عن منطقه
كهرمان مرعش وبقيت طفله ثالثه موجوده هنا
في هذه المنطقه مع خالها وهم الان يتلقون
العلاج اللازم الطالب بالنسبه لاسرتها
للاسف هي اسره مكونه من ست اشخاص توفي
الاب والام
والشقيقه رابعه توفيت لكن كان يعني نصيب
ثلاث الطفلات التي خرجنا اليوم هو النجاه
من تحت الانقاض منذ سته ايام وطالب يعني
الشعور كان لا يوصف في تلك اللحظه خروج
هؤلاء الطفلات الثلاث الصغيرات خصوصا اخر
طفله عائشه التي بقيت يعني تاخرت لمده
اربع ساعات ونصف حين اخرجوها من تحت
الانقاض يعني كان شعورا لا يوصف بصراحه
طالب وكان الوضع قاسي جدا خصوصا على
اقارب
الطفلات الثلاث اخوالهم وجدهم قلنا نحن
انه الاب والام والشقيقه الرابعه توفيت
للاسف لكن يعني كان الوضع ماساوي جدا وكان
الوضع ايضا يعني جو مش جو جو مختلط بالفرح
والحزن والبكاء والصدمه يعني حال الاخوال
كان لا يصدق يعني كانوا هم غير مصدقين ما
جرى لماذا لانهم بالامس طالب ابلغوهم ان
هناك جثتين لطفلتين ثم جاءوا ليتعرفوا
عليهن فكانت الجثث مشوهه يعني
رؤوس مشوهه لم يستطيعوا التعرف عليهن فهم
يعني سلموا امرهم لله ويعني يعني فقدوا
الامل لكن بعد ذلك
يعني جاءت انباء بان هناك ناجين ما زالوا
تحت هذه الانقاض وهم اطفال وبالتالي تجدد
الامل مجددا لهم وبقيوا بانتظار
هؤلاء الاطفال الى حين خروجهم وتم يعني
اخراجهم بسلامه وايضا هناك انباء تتوالى
طالب من مدن اخرى ومن كهرمان مرعش
بانتشال ايضا ناجين من تحت الانقاذ بينهم
اطفال صغار رضع وبينهم مسنين وبينهم نساء
ورجال
فقط لنشير يعني يبدو ان هنالك انتشال لعدد
من الجثث نلاحظ يعني رجال انقاذ بعض
الاكياس السوداء وبعض يعني الستائر
الستائر كما لو توصف لنا يعني لعندما توضع
هذه الست
اكياس من النايلون السوداء فيعني ان هنالك
جثث يتم استخراجها ليس كذلك نعم
نعم صحيح نعم صحيح طالب هذه مؤشرات واضحه
عندما تكون هناك اكياس سوداء فهي اكياس
الجثث يتم وضعها في هذه الاكياس وعندما
تكون ستائر بهذه الطريقه يعني ندرك تماما
بانها جثه لانها لو كانت لو كان شخصا حيا
او يحاولون اخراجه لكان الوضع مختلف تماما
لرايت العديد من عمال الانقاذ هرعوا الى
هذا المكان لرايت حركه اسرع من هكذا في
التعامل مع اخراج الشخص الناجي لرايت ايضا
المسعفين والنقاله وايضا التغذيه تكون
موجوده مع
مسعفين للتعامل بشكل سريع وطارق مع الشخص
الذي يتم انتشاله من تحت الانقاذ ان كان
ناجيا لكن في مثل هذا الموقف واضح تماما
انها جثه لشخص او ربما اكثر من جثه لا
ندري نحن قبلك يومين كنا هنا وابلغونا قبل
يومين طالب بالمناسبه ان هذا المبنى كان
عدد من الاشخاص احياء تقريبا خمسه اشخاص
كانوا احياء بينهم اطفال لكن اليوم نحن
بعد يومين نحن نقف امام مشهد مختلف الان
طالب المشهد هو عباره عن ستائر واكياس جثث
موجوده في هذا المكان لا توجد حركه وتجاوب
سريع من المنقذين لانهم مدركين تماما انهم
يتعاملون مع جثه هي يعني دقائق ويتم
انتشال هذه الجثه ما يجري بعد ذلك طالب ان
كان هنا احد من الاهالي
قريب او له علاقه بهذا المبنى يكون في
انتظار
الاشخاص او الجثث التي تخرج ويتم التعرف
عليهم في حال تم التعرف عليهم طالب يدفنون
فورا في حال لم يتم التعرف عليهم ينقلون
الى مستشفيات قريبه ويوضعون في تلك
المستشفيات لمده 24 ساعه يفتحوا المجال
امام الناس الباحثين عن
المفقودين للتعرف عليهم بالوجه بالشكل
هناك جثث مشوهه طالب يصعب التعرف عليها
لذا يعني يستدلون الاهالي عبر اللباس عبر
الشكل الشكل الحجم وما الى ذلك ومن لم يتم
التعرف عليه من من هذه الجثث الجثث طالب
يتم اخذ عينه من الحمض النووي اضافه الى
المواصفات مواصفات الجثه الطول والوزن
واللباس الوان الوان اللباس ويتم تقييدها
واعطائها رقم ودفنها بعد 24 ساعه طالب نحن
نتحدث عن الالاف هنا هنا غسان ادرك ان
السؤال قاسي جدا ولكن هل يتم عمليات الدفن
بمقابر جماعيه لما لما بنشوف نحن انه عدد
القتلى والضحايا يرتفع بالمئات يعني بكون
في ساعه بتشوف انه قفز الرقم مثلا من مثلا
20 الف الى 21 الف سنه 22 الف طيب
الجثث
التي سواء التي يتم التعرف عليها او التي
لا يتم التعرف عليها عندما تكون بهذه
الاعداد تقام لها مراسم بشكل اعتيادي
مراسم دفن ام لا تدفن بمقابر جماعيه
طالب يعني لم نسمع حتى اللحظه عن وجود
مقابر جماعيه هذا الامر لم نسمع عنه
نهائيا من يتم التعرف عليه ياتي اهله
وياخذوه
يقوموا بعمليه الدفن واجراءات الدفن
المعتاده في المقابر الموجوده يعني
المقابر المنتشره في كل منطقه لم نسمع عن
وجود مقابر جماعيه اما بالنسبه للجثث التي
تبقى مجهوله كما قلنا تتولاها السلطات
وتقوم بدفنها طالب بعد 24 ساعه يعني حتى
اللحظه لا شيء مؤكد ولا يوجد معلومات عن
هذا الشيء من هذا القبيل يعني اعتقد انهم
يدفنون في المقابر العاديه لانه لا يوجد
نحن نتحدث عن سته ايام لو كان هناك مقابر
جماعيه لكان يعني كان هذا الامر واضحا
واعلن عنه لكن
اعتقد انهم يدفنون في المقابر الموزعه في
كل مناطق نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 21 الف
قتيل حتى هذه اللحظه طالب وما زال هناك
نعم بالفعل طالب كما اشرت هناك وسائل
مختلفه ومتعدده وهناك اليات مختلفه
ومتعدده طبعا الاليات الثقيله التي
تشاهدها بالصوره لا ادري ان كنت تشاهدها
ام لا هناك
فقط رافعه فقط
هذه الاليات الثقيله تبدا
هذه الان ستشاهد الصوره بشكل اوضح طالب
هذه الاليات الثقيله طالب تتدخل في
المراحل الاولى تقوم بسحب وازاله الطبقات
الكبيره والضخمه جدا من الاسمنت المسلح
والانقاذ ثم تتدخل العناصر البشريه من فرق
الانقاذ باستخدام وسائل متوسطه الحجم
ثقيله لكنها متوسطه الحجم تستخدم بالايدي
يقومون ايضا بتحطيم الركام وتكسير الرقاق
الركام ومن ثم بعد ذلك حين يقترب من الشخص
الناجي الموجود تحت الانقاض يستخدمون
الوسائل العاديه اليدويه مثل المطرقه
والمعاون والازاميل وما الى ذلك لماذا
لانه في هذه المرحله هم يقتربون من العالق
تحت الانقاذ ولا يريدون ان يتسببوا اي خطا
هي عمليه معقده طالب معقده جدا وصعبه
وطويله وتاخذ وقت طويل وهذه المشكله
فبالتالي هم يتعاملون بحرص شديد وحذر شديد
حتى لا يكون هناك اي خطا اي خطا كارثي
طالب اي خطا كارثه ان كان هناك شخص ناجن
ووقع خطا ما في خلال عمليه ازاله الانقاذ
ممكن ان يؤدي الى انهيار جديد وبالتالي
فقدان هذا الشخص لذلك هم يتعاملون بنفس
طويل جدا طالب ويقومون بازاله هذه الانقاذ
المرحله الاخيره يستخدمون فيها يستخدمون
فيها الادوات البسيطه مثل المطارق وما الى
ذلك لازاحه الانقاض ومن ثم فتح مجال لسحب
هذا الشخص الان كما تشاهد الطالب يقومون
برفع هذه الجثه سنبقي الصوره واسعه حتى
يعني نحترم طبعا خصوصيه الوفاه
يعني هذه جثه او اكثر من جثه
المشاهد تفطر الطلبيه يسحبوها
غسان يعني ولكن مشاهد قاسي ومؤلمه طالب
مشاهد مؤلمه وقاسيه وتتكرر كل ساعه وكل
لحظه وكل دقيقه في عموم المدن التي تعرضت
للزلزال مشاهد مؤلمه جدا بالفعل مشاهد
مؤلمه جدا طالب لكن هناك ايضا بصيص الم
امل وهناك فرح ياتي من تحت الانقاذ دائما
هناك
دائما
يعني ويا رب الهم الجميع الصبر يعني نتيجه
ما نرى غسان سؤال اخير قبل ان انتقل الى
زملائك يعني الذين يغطون اخبار الزلزال من
مناطق اخرى طيب بالنسبه الى المبنى الذي
يتم التاكد انه ما في احياء يعني مبنى
مهدم ولكن تاكدوا ما في احياء كيف يتم
التعامل معه يتم جرفه ام لا يعني هنا
السؤال في مبنى ممكن يكون في شكوك في
احياء تحدثت شرحت انت كيف يتم التعامل مع
ذلك ولكن اذا كان المبنى يعني اذا تاكد
انه احياء كيف تتعامل فرق الانقاذ مع هذا
المبنى
طالب بطبيعه الحال هناك توجيهات واضحه
وصارمه من السلطات التركيه ومن الرئاسه
التركيه العمل على مدار الساعه لاعاده
الاعمار فاي مبنى يتم التاكد من خلوه من
العالقين او من الجثث تتم الاليه تقوم
الاليات بشكل مباشر وفورا بازاله الانقاذ
وهذا ما نلاحظه بام العين هناك المئات من
الاليات التي تقوم بهذه الانقاذ هناك
المئات من الاليات التي تقوم برفع هذه
الانقاذ على مدار الساعه هم مصممون على
اعاده اعمار هذه المناطق خلال عام كما
تعهد الرئيس اردوغان وتامين المساكن
الجديده للعائلات المتضرره اما في حال
وجود اي شكوك بوجود اشخاص ما زالوا عالقين
تحت الانقاذ تتم عمليات ومواصله الانقاذ
او انتشال الجثث من تحت الانقاض لا يمكن
ازاله اي مبنى بالكامل الا عندما يتاكدوا
بانه لا يوجد اي شخص تحت الانقاذ وبالتالي
العمليات مستمره ومتواصله على مدار الساعه
ايضا على مدار الساعه يتم ازاله هذه
الانقاض وبالمناسبه طالب هناك ابنيه اي
للسقوط ليس فقط هذه الانقاد يعني سنريك
مثل هذه المباني هذه المباني خطيره جدا لا
يسمح لنا بالاقتراب اليها مثلا ولا لاي
شخص لانه في اي لحظه ممكن ان تظهر خصوصا
مع ظل استمرار طالب الاهتزازات الارتداديه
نتحدث عن اكثر
التغطيه وكل هذه المعلومات وهذه الصوره
التي تنقلها الينا غسان من قهرمان مرعش
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المتابعه
وخلال عمل عناصر لفرق الانقاذ فيها انهارت
الانقاذ عليهم اثناء محاولات انتشار
الاحياء من تحت الركام
ومن تحت الانقاب قالت السلام عليكم هكذا
نطقت الطفله رنا جاما البالغه من العمر 12
عاما بمجرد انقاذها ما جعل رجال الانقاذ
والحشد يهللون من حولها نشاهد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا وما يزال اهالي الضحايا العالقين تحت
الانقاد جراء الزلزال في تركيا يرافقون
فرق الانقاذ والبحث لتلقي اي اخبار عن
ذويهم رغم المؤشرات بعدم وجود ناجين هناك
كان يعيش اخي وخالتي بعد انهيار البناء
قفزوا من النافله لا اعلم ان كان علي
الفرح لانهم القوا بانفسهم ونجوا او احزن
على من فقدوا ارواحهم هناك
[موسيقى]
لعل هناك امل لكن على ما يبدو الامل
يتضاءل
اقرب حسب ما نعلم ان هناك ستين شخصا تحت
ركام هذا المبنى فقدوا ارواحهم والان 14
شخصا تحت الانقاض ما زالوا هناك حتى هذه
اللحظه من بينهم اقاربي
[موسيقى]
في بدايه الزلزال انهار المبنى وقيل لنا
لا يوجد مؤشر على وجود ناجين لكن بقينا
ننتظر
[موسيقى]
انتقل الان الى ريف ادلب ينضم الي لمزيد
من المتابع الصحفي محمد الاشقر محمد اهلا
وسهلا بك بدايه جديد الصوره من عندك واخر
تحديث للمعلومات التي والارقام التي
تريدكم من ريف ادلب سواء لعدد الضحايا عدد
القتلى الجرحى المشرده
نعم يعني في الحقيقه الى حد هذه اللحظه لا
توجد احصائيه رسميه او نهائيه لاعداد
الضحايا سواء كانوا قتلى او جرحى بحسب
لجنه الاستجابه الطارئه فقد قالوا ان
اعداد القتلى قد وصلت الى
2600 قتيل اما اعداد الجرحى فقد تخطت عتبه
الخمسه الاف وثمانمائه
مصاب طبعا هؤلاء الضحايا نتيجه الزلزال
الذي ضرب المنطقه في عده مناطق شمال غرب
سوريا الى حد هذه اللحظه كما ذكرت لك لا
توجد احصائيه نهائيه ولا رسميه ربما في
الساعات القليله القادمه ستبدا الحصيله
الرسميه بالظهور خصوصا ان الفرق الانقاذ
والمشرفين على فرق الفرق التطوعيه وفرق
الدفاع المدني وبعض الناشطين بداوا بالعمل
برسم
الاحصائيه الرسميه لاعداد
القتلى والمصابين نتيجه هذا الزلزال طبعا
تستمر فرق الدفاع المدني في انتشال
الضحايا في بعض المناطق هنا حيث نتواجد في
مدينه السلقين كانوا اليوم
يواصلون البحث عن ثلاثه
اطفال في المدينه في احد الابنيه بعد ان
وصلهم بلاغ بوجود ثلاثه اطفال لا يوجد
تاكيد حول انهم متوفين او ما زالوا احياء
ويحتاجون للانتشال تحت الارقام فقط
للمقاطعه ساعود اليك بعد قليل ولكن مؤتمر
صحفي لوزير الداخليه التركي نتابع مباشره
على الهواء
كارثه العصر
يسعى بعضهم لرفع روح التضامن بين الناس
يسعون خلف مصالحهم السياسيه لتذهب مصالحكم
السياسيه الى الجحيم
نحن نسعى لتضميد هذه الجراح قولوا خيرا او
اصمتوا لا تقولون خيرا ولا تصمتون بل
تسمعون في الشر هذا معيب
واكدنا على نقطه اخرى لكل مواطنين
في الولايات المحافظات العشق في تركيا مع
اعمال الاخلاء
هنالك ما يزيد على سبعين الف شرطي وما
يزيد على 60 الف دركي من عناصر الجندرمه
المجموع 130 الف وايضا هناك خف السواحل
131 الف
الان هنالك الاجهزه
تحقق الامن الى
المحافظات وحتى القرى وتقوم بالنقل ودعم
اللوجستي والتناقلي هنالك جهود مستميته
يقوم بها تقوم بها هذه هي الاجهزه الامنيه
لكن اولئك المشوهين والمحافظين طبعا ده
يسعون في فتره شعبنا اشد ما يكون فيها
حاجه الى الداميه العون يحاولون تفرقه هذا
الشعب وتشكيله هذه التصورات المغلوطه نعيش
هذا كله
ما من ذنب او جريمه ستموجود دون عقوبه
الان تم اعتقال العديد من الناس بسبب هذه
الاحداث التي ذكرتها هناك ميزه عليها
عشرين حادثه اعتقال جرت وكل حادثه
اصدقائنا يقومون باللازم بشانها
اصدقائنا يقومون بتامين المساكن والمخيمات
والطرق
اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر المؤتمر الصحفي
لوزير الداخليه التركيه سليمان صويلو
بالطبع كان يتحدث عن عمليات النهب والسلب
والنشر الشائعات قال سنحاسب من يقوم
بعمليه النهب والسلب وسنحاسب من ينشر
الشائعات ولقد نفذنا حتى الساعه عشرين
عمليه اعتقال بحق هؤلاء اعلن رئيس قسم
الحد من المخاطر باداره الطوارئ والكوارث
في تركيا اورخان تتار اعلن ان الزلزال
الذي ضرب البلاد في السادس من فبراير
استمر لدقيقتين وعادل من وجهه النظر
العلميه انفجار 500 قنبله ذريه
[موسيقى]
لمزيد من المتابعه ايضا معي من باريس الان
الدكتور وحيد احمد وهو طبيب امراض صدريه
وعنايه مشدده دكتور وحيد اهلا وسهلا بك
كونك من اهل الاختصاص بدايه هل يمكن
العثور على ناجين بعد اكثر من 130 ساعه
تحت الانقاد ام لا يعني هذا الامر في حكم
المستحيل او المعجزات
اهلا وسهلا بك
بالمشاهدين نحن ناسف لما يجري وقلوبنا
معكم ومع
الذين تحت الانقاض ومع الذين يعملوا على
نجاتهم للاسف لا شك بانه هناك
الان يعني ضعف في احتمال
نلاقي احياء ولكن ليس بالمستحيل نعم في
سوابق من هذا القبيل استطعت ان نجد احياء
بعد عشرين يوم او 25 يوم حتى ولكن هذا
يعني نادر جدا ويحتاج الى قوى نجده والى
تعادد والى امكانيات كبيره نعم انا انا
اعرف دكتور ان هذا السؤال ربما صعب ولكن
تعرف لا حياء في العلم نشوف جثث يتم
استخراجها اذا نظرت اليها تكون سليمه مئه
بالمئه ولكن في وفاه طب هون الوفاه حاصله
من ماذا يعني من ضيق التنفس من من ماذا او
مثلا من عدم وجود ماء عدم طعام كيف نفسر
ذلك
سيدي الكريم لا شك بانه في مثل هذه
الحالات هناك عده اشياء اساسيه للحياه
اولها وجود الهواء
ثانيا بالاهميه وجود الماء سواء كانت
بالصرف الصحي او الامطار او غيره ووجود
الطعام ليس له اهميه كبيره في الحالي في
الساعات الاولى في الايام الاولى المساحه
التي وجد فيها تحت الانقاد هل هناك مجال
هل هناك انضغاط هل هناك كسور جراح الى
اخره لكن اهم شيء بالموضوع هو فقدان
الاكسجين والغبار وجود الغبار ووجود الضغط
على الجسم لا شك انه يؤثر على التنفس
ويؤثر على القلب وتكون الوفاه سريعه ولا
شك اي رد على الراس على الدماغ يعطي
مباشره غيبوبه ويموت المريض لانه ليس له
متنفس وليس له اكسجين طيب دكتور وحيد
الذين كتبت لهم النجاه وخرجوا من تحت
الانقاض
مما سيعانون في المستقبل وما هي النصائح
التي يمكن اعطائها
طبعا حسب
[موسيقى]
الجسديه سابقا حسب الامراض المزمنه اللي
عنده او لا حسب القدره النفسيه والعقليه
والصحي والصحيه اللي عنده لذلك لا شك من
الناحيه الفيزيائيه سنستطيع متى ما خرج من
تحت الانقاض وكان في هناك
اول وكان فيه توجه نحو المشاكل الخاصه
السريعه فهو من الناحيه الصحيه الجسديه
على ما يرام ربما
بجيب بشكل جيد ولكن تبقى الناحيه النفسيه
والصحيه والعقليه يعني تتصور حضرتك واحد
تحت الانقاد يعني
بالموت ما تتنفس ما في حدا حواليه فسيح لا
شك دكتور وحيد انا كمان ساستغل وجودك معنا
لو سمحت شاهدنا يعني حتى اليوم يعني ثلاثه
اطفال نكن اكثر تحديدا ثلاث بنات يعني تحت
العاشره من العمر تم انقاذهم بعد سته ايام
يعني ما الذي يعني من خلال هذه الحادثه ما
الذي ساعونيه الاطفال الذين مروا بهذه
التجربه وما هي النصائح ايضا
اولا
استنشاق لمواد ضاره وهذا سنستطيع
قلت
وسيتم ان شاء الله
العلاج بشكل جيد من ناحيه الجسديه لكن
العضويه ولكن تبقى
الاثار النفسيه المريره التي سيعانون منها
مع فقدان الاهل بالدرجه الاولى
بمجرد الوجود بالعزله والوحده والاحساس
بالموت الحقيقي الذي سياتي مضيق التنفس
سيؤدي الى اثار نفسيه ويجب المتابعه
النفسيه والعقليه بشكل كبير
ومن باريس الدكتور وحيد احمد طبيب امراض
صدريه وعينيه مشدده شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
انا يعني هن طالعوني
صرت اضحك لتحت
ساعدني ساعدوني
ساعدوني الشباب
وطالعوني اخذونا
[موسيقى]
مش
ضمدوا لي جرحي وما عرفت ايش صار مع امي
ومع ابوي واختي ديمه طلعوها فقت اول خفيفه
تاني زلزاله قويه كان بدها تنزل الحجر على
اخوي انت وقفت فوقه قام نزلت علي على صدري
وبعدين اخوي انطمر اختي توفت وستي توفت
واخوي الحمد لله وابوي ما فيه شي صلي عليه
لا تخاف تمام
يا خالو معلش
وانا حفيان
انه في حد عندك جوه اما اخواتي بس
ميتين
هذا وقالت مديره اداره البرامج والمكتب
الاقليميه لشرق المتوسط التابعه لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه رنا الحجه قالت ان نحو 200
الف سوري بمحافظه حلب باتوا بلا ماوى جراء
الدمار الذي الحقه الزلزال بمباني المدينه
وحثت في مؤتمر صحفي المجتمع الدولي على
تقديم المزيد من المساعدات لاغاثه ضحايا
الزلزال
اود ان اشدد على ان المجتمع الدولي قدم
الكثير من الالتزامات وعبر عن اراده كبيره
في حشد المساعده هناك الكثير من الجهود
المبذوله لتقديم المساعدات للمتضررين لكن
لا تزال هناك حاجه ماسه لزياده المساعدات
لان حجم الدمار هائل
على كل لمزيد من المتابعه ايضا اذهب الى
دمشق ينضم الي من هناك المتحدث باسم
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في سوريا
عدنان حزام استاذ عدنان اهلا وسهلا بك اي
تقييم للوضع الان في اليوم السادس لهذا
الزلزال المدمر واي سوره يمكن ان تنقلها
الينا سواء على مستوى عدد الضحايا اخر
تحديث للارقام التي وردتكم عدد الجرحى عدد
المشردين وابرز الاحتياجات التي يعني يجب
ان تحصلوا عليها باسرع وقت ممكن لاغاثه
الجرح
طبعا
الوضع
يزداد صيدليه خاصه وان هناك فرص قليله
لاحتمال وجود ناجين مع ذلك تستمر هذه
العمليات عمليه الانقاذ وكذلك عمليه تقديم
العمله الانساني
لضحايا هذه الكارثه خاصه ان هناك انشئت
مراكز للاباء
المدينه التي حلب واللاذقيه وحماه تقوم
اللجنه بالاحمر مع فرق الهلال الاحمر
بالتوزيع المواد الغذائيه وكذلك الايوائيه
لمن هم في هذه المراكز طبعا ما نقدمه هو
شيء بسيط
مقارنه بالوضع الحالي والاحتياجات الكبيره
والعدد الهائل من الاسر المتواجده في تلك
المراكز للاسف الشديد الوضع الانساني بهذه
الكارثه
صعب للغايه ومحزن كثير نحن نحن نحاول قدر
المستطاع التقليد من هذه من هذه من اثر
هذه
استاذ عدنان يعطيكم الف عافيه بطبيعه
الحال هذا العمل الانساني لو تعطينا بعض
المعلومات عدد القوافل المساعدات التي
وصلتكم وكيف يتم توزيعها يعني تصل في
الوقت المحدد ام لا في تحديات عم بتواجهكم
في موضوع توزيع هذه المساعدات
طبعا نحن في اللهجه الدولي بالاحمر لدينا
الياتنا في عمليه التوزيع كوننا لدينا
كوننا موجودين في هذه البلد التي تعاني
باكثر من 12 عاما من النزاع نقوم
باخراج المواد من المخازن وتقديمها
للمتضررين طبعا ما قدمناه لا يفيد الغرض
ولذلك سيكون هناك المزيد في الايام
القادمه خاصه في المواد الايوائيه
والجراحيه والطبيه والغذائيه بتعرف يعني
في في وضع يعني الوضع في سوريا وضع غير
طبيعي لانه في مناطق قاضعه للحكومه في
مناطق خاضعه لمقاتلي المعارضه اولا كيف
يعني بالنسبه الى المناطق الخاضعه التي
ليست خاضعه لسيطره الحكومه السوريه هل
لديكم داله على المساعدات هناك ارسال
المساعدات اليهم توزيع المساعدات هناك ام
لا لا وجود لاي قنوات تواصل
طبعا من اللجنه الدوليه الصليب الاحمر حتى
قبل هذه
الكارثه تحاول الوصول للمناطق الاخرى
التي تعاني من الازمه وكذلك الان
نقوم بالتواصلاتنا من اجل الوصول لجميع
المناطق المتاثره بهذا بهذه الكارثه طبعا
اريد ان اوضح هنا ان هناك منظمات كثيره
تعمل على الارض السوريه
والعمل الانساني متكامل سواء كان في شماله
او غربها او جنوبها الوقت الوقت الان جاء
لصوت الانساني يجب ان يكون هناك السمح
لدخول المزيد من المساعدات وان يكون هناك
تقديم للمساعدات وتسير عمليه عمل المنظمات
الانسانيه من دمشق المتحدث باسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في سوريا عدنان
حزام شكرا جزيلا
حزامه ويعطيكم الف عافيه
وهذا ويعقد مجلس الامن الاسبوع المقبل
جلسه لمناقشه امكانيه السماح للامم
المتحده بارسال مساعدات الى شمال غرب
سوريا عبر اكثر من معبر حدودي تركي وذلك
بعد سقوط الاف القتلى والجرحى جراء
الزلزال المدمر الذي وقع الاثنين الماضي
لكن روسيا لا تعتقد ان هذه الخطوه ضروريه
فيما يصفها النظام تعديا على سيادته
مشترطا التنسيق معه وتسليم المساعدات عبر
الخطوط الاماميه للحرب الاهليه المستمره
منذ 12 عاما وفق ما نقلت وكاله
مسؤول امريكي ذكرز ان واشنطن تضغط على
مجلس الامن الدولي لاعتماد قرار اخر قد
يسمح بمعابر حدوديه اضافيه من جهه اخرى
يشترط النظام تسليم المساعدات عبر الخطوط
الاماميه للوصول الى المحتاجين نائب سفير
روسيا لدى الامم المتحده والذي تتمتع
بلاده بحق الفيتو يؤيد الطرحه السوري وانه
يمكن ايصال المساعدات عبر الخطوط الاماميه
اي عن طريق معابر تسيطر عليها الحكومه
فيما عبر دبلوماسيون عن املهم في ان تكون
شهاده منسق الامم المتحده للمساعدات مارتن
جرافيث المتوقع ان يزور سوريا مقنعه
لروسيا وللحكومه من اجل الموافقه على فتح
نقطه او اكثر عبر الحدود لعبور هذه
المساعده
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي من
موسكو الان السيد وهو المحلل السياسي اهلا
وسهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه واشنطن كما
ذكرنا تضغط لعقد جلسه جديده لمجلس الامن
الدولي في محاوله لفتح معابر جديده للوصول
الى الى سوريا لايصال المساعدات الموقف
الروسي المعروف كان لا يشهر الفيتو بحق
هكذا مشاريع باعتبار ان ذلك لا يتم
بالتنسيق مع الحكومه السوريه الان هل
سيتغير الموقف الروسي بمعنى انه الضرورات
تبيح المحظورات وان الظرف طارئ جدا وضاغط
فيجب على روسي ان تقبل بذلك والا تشهر
الفيتو
لا تقبل كل اقتراحات الامريكيه من هذا
النوع السبب واضح ان هي تحاول ان تغطي
النشاط التخريبي في سيريا ومساعده للقوه
المواجهه لسلطه سوريا على طريقه المساعدات
الانسانيه مساعدات الانسانيه هذا امر
العاجل ضروري
وتحتاج اهتمام لاكثر
امكانيه الممكنه ولذلك محاوله طاقت الغتال
تفتح الابواب لمساعده القوه المواجهه
للسلطه السوريه هذا امر
سياسي وليست انساني اذا منظمات الدوليه
التي ترسله بعض
الموادوز الا يمكن ايجاد صيغه وسط فقط
يعني من اجل التعامل مع الماساه يعني الان
لا يوجد طرف يعني للمماحات السياسيه في
مجلس الامن الان يجب التصرف سريعا وايصال
المساعدات والمساعدات لا تفرق هنا لا يجب
ان تفرق بين من هو يعني في مناطق سيطره
الحكومه او في مناطق سيطره المعارضه
100% هذا هو اقتراح الروسي لان هي تعتبر
انه
السوريه باحتراما لسياده السوريه لازم ان
يكون
لقبول الكل المساعدات مؤسسات الرسميه
سوريا
امريكا لا تعترف شرعيه الدوله السوريه
لماذا هي لا ترسل مساعدات الطبيه لمناطق
الكارثيه في سوريا عبر مطر حلب مثلا
انا منذ ساعه تقريبا
كنت اتراجع على عبر الانترنت مطار الحلب
غير مدرب لماذا يرفض ارسال المواد
الانسانيه الى هذا المطر ويرسلون الى
المطار غازيانتير
مطار تركي وهذا طالما سيد باتيس والله ما
ذكرت تركيا يعني بتعرف كانت موسكو تسعى في
الاونه الاخيره الى تقارب والى اعاده
العلاقات بين انقره ودمشق هل تعتقد الان
ان ما جرى وهول هذا الزلزال سيسرع من
عمليه التقارب وبالطبع اعاده العلاقات بين
انقره ودمشق ام لا يعني هذا لن يكون له اي
تاثير
السياسيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
من واشنطن معي الان ارام الدوماني وهو
امين سر التحالف الوطني السوري المعارض
ومنسق ايقافله الطوارئ في مناطق شرق سوريا
الى مناطق الشمال السوري قبل ان اسالك ان
ترد على ما قاله السيد على الموقف الروسي
ان صح التعبير اولا سيد دوماني الصليب
الاحمر قال انه قوافل المساعدات بدات تعبر
وبشكل سلس يعني من مناطق سيطره الحكومه
الى مناطق المعارضه بشكل طبيعي عبر معبر
باب الهوى ما هي معلوماتكم هل تستطيع ان
تؤكد ذلك
مرحبا طبعا هذا هو مسار الستانى مسار
موسكو
وانقره اتجاه
التقارب مع النظام السوري على حساب دماء
الشعب السوري لا يزال الشعب السوري يعاني
حتى في الكوارث الانسانيه حتى
هم اشد
الايام الصعوبه وهو في كارثه
الزلزال المدمر
يعني هذا المسار الذي ياتي ايضا يعني يعني
لا ادري ماذا اقول لا ادري ماذا نقول نحن
الشعب السوري ابتلانا الله بنظام
مجرماني استاذ لو تركنا السياسه جانبا
يعني والمماحات التي نسمعها بين النظام
وبين المعارضه على الدوام الان في ظرف
ضاغط قاهر مفجع يستوجب على الجميع التعاون
والتعاضد يعني الا تعتقد انه حان الوقت
يعني في هذا الظرف ان يكون هنالك قنوات
اتصال مع النظام في سوريا على الاقل فقط
لغرض واحد ايصال المساعدات
نحن مع جميع
الاستقبال المساعدات من جميع المناطق نحن
لدينا مشكله حاليا
الاداره الذاتيه في شمال شرق سوريا
جهزت قامت بتجهيز بقوافل مساعدات ولكن
الجهات المختصه في الشمال الغربي ترفض
استقبال هذه المساعدات معبر باب السلامه
لا يزال مغلق معبر باب الهواء ايضا لا
يزال مغلق لماذا لا نكرس جهودنا من اجل
اتخاذ قرار انساني نحن لسنا ضد اغلاق
المعابر ايضا
باتجاه النظام نحن مع دخول الهلال الاحمر
والصليب الاحمر من الناحيه الانسانيه نحن
في التحالف السوري الوطني
لسنا اصحاب قرار ولسنا اصحاب سلطه في
الشمال الغربي ولكن نحن ندعو جميع الاطراف
ان يقوموا بواجبه من انساني اتجاه الشعب
السوري لماذا الائتلاف
السوارد والحكومه المؤقته لم يقبلوا
استقبال القوافل الانسانيه من الاداره
الذاتيه في شمال وشمال شرق سوريا هل هم
بحاجه الى قرار سياسي تركي
هناك تسييس ايضا في المعابر
المعابر الانسانيه نحن نواجه مشكله
المعابر هذه المعابر منذ اشهر منذ سنين
نواجه هذه المشكله وروسيا وتركيا وايران
والفيتو الروسي الصيني الى الى ما كل كل
ذلك من اجل التطبيع مع النظام السوري
استاذ ارام انا ساكتفي بهذا القدر من
واشنطن ارام الدوماني وهو امين سر التحالف
الوطني السوري المعارض ومنسق قافله
الطوارئ في مناطق شرق سوريا الى مناطق
شمال سوريا شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
في سوريا الزلزال يعيد فتح ملف كاد يونس
خمسه فاصله ثلاثه مليون شخص على حافه
التشرد بفعل الزلزال
تقديرات اوليه اعلنتها مفوضيه الامم
المتحده للاجئين هذا رقم ضخم لدى شعب
يعاني اساسا من نزوح جماعي تقول ممثله
المفوضيه في سوريا قبل زلزال هناك نحو
6.8 مليون نازح داخل سوريا بسبب الحرب منذ
عام 2011
معاناه ليست جديده لكن فاقم الزلزال من
حدتها
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين سنواصل معكم هذه التغطيه
ولكن نتوقف مع بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات
اخرى حيث قال المستشار بالرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بوليات ان حديث روسيا
عن عدم مغادره اراضي اوكرانيا
تدلي بها عن السلام والمحادثات هو دليل
اخر على ان المحادثات بين الجانبين
مستبعده مضيفا انه اما ان تنتصر اوكرانيا
او تظل الحرب في اوروبا بلا نهايه
من روسيا بشكل اجرامي على العالم على حد
وصف
هذا واعلن نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه عن
استعداد بلاده للتفاوض مع كيف دون شروط
مسبقه مشددا على مراعاه المفاوضات لاهداف
الروسيه
المسبقه الاعلان عنها قال ايضا ان قرار
المفاوضات مع موسكو لا يتخذ في كييف بل في
واشنطن او بروكسل متهما الجانب الاوكراني
بقطع المفاوضات رغم بدء روسيا بها فعليا
افادت صحيفه
الالمانيه عن زياده في اعمال التجسس التي
يقوم بها عملاء للمخابرات الايرانيه على
المعارضين الايرانيين الذين يعيشون في
المانيا في الفتره الماضيه مؤكده على ان
عمليات التجسس زادت بشكل كبير بعد بدء
الاحتجاجات في ايران وفقا للصحيفه فقد
قالت الحكومه الالمانيه ان الحكام في
ايران يعتبرون جماعات المعارضه الايرانيه
تحديدا لاستمراريه النظام
دعا الفرنسيون الى تعبئه جديده ضد اصلاح
نظام التقاعد والذي لا يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره
بين اوساط الفرنسيين
وتامل النقابات الفرنسيه في مشاركه كبيره
في التظاهرات التي تنظم في يوم السبت اي
في عطله نهايه الاسبوع ليتاح للعاملين غير
القادرين على الاضراب بالمشاركه في هذه
التظاهرات
كما ذكرت بعض المصادر انه من المتوقع ان
يشارك في التظاهرات ما بين 600 الف الى
800 الف شخص من مختلف مناطق البلاد
اضافت واشنطن سته شركات صينيه على لائحتها
السوداء بعد تدميرها منتاضا صينيا قالت
انه مجهز بادوات تجسس وكان يحلق فوق مواقع
عسكريه حساسه ما يعني منعه تلك الشركات من
الوصول الى التقنيات والسلع الامريكيه من
دون اذن وقال نائب وزير التجاره ان
اللائحه السوداء للولايات المتحده التي
شملت الشركات الصينيه ست تعتبر اداه قويه
لتحديد ومنع الجهات التي تسعى لاستخدام
وصولها الى الاسواق العالميه لالحاق الضرر
بالامن القومي الامريكي وتهديده
بعد قليل تلقاكم الزميله رشا نبيل في
استكمال هذه التغطيه حول الزلزال الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته